In 1943 we see the tide really turns in favor of the allies
especially in Europe but it's actually happening in the Pacific as well
to begin with in 1943 the siege of Stalingrad
which doesn't quite exactly fit on this map
but would be right over here
it ends with the soviets being notorious
and this is actually an incredible story
there's many movies about the siege of Stalingrad for a reason
the soviets are able to mount a pretty epic counterattack
by attacking the flanks of the axis army
and their able to push the back and defeat the axis army
Stalingrad itself gets reduced to rubble
and you know if you actually look up pictures of it
its kind of mind blowing to just even imagine what went on there
and Stalingrad right over here
although right now Leningrad in 1943 still under siege
and if you want your stomach to really be sick
look up images of things that happened over there
but needless to say 1943 its a turning...
or its not the turning point '42 really is the turning point
but in 1943, the momentum's really in the allies
favor the Soviets defeat the Germans at Stalingrad
they are able to push the Germans and the axis powers out of the caucases
and then they'd begin to advance
and then the Soviets begin to advance and retake ground from the axis powers
now at the same time you might remember
that at the end of 1942 in North Africa
in North Africa, let me go right over here
I have all these maps layered over here
you might remember that the British were able to
push back the axis army back into Lybia
and then this just continues as we go into 1943
and the allied armies essentially able to kick the axis army out of North Africa
be victorious of North Africa
you remember you have these the armies that are coming from Egypt
you also had allies land in Morocco and Algeria
and then they all meet up
and by mid-year they're able to use their victory in North Africa
as a launching point to start attacking the main land of Italy
they first, they can go to Sicily
or then they go to the actual main land, and there's an attack at Selerno
and they start to really kind of fight their way up the Italian peninsula
we're gonna do this in a blue color so you can see
this is the allies, as were going to mid- and late- 1943
are able to take more and more of the Italian peninula
now as this happens, conditions i Italy aren't good
the Italian people aren't happy
and they're actually able to depose Mussolini
so let me write that down
so this is, In 1943 Mussolini, oh i think there's another s, Mussolini is deposed
Mussolini is, Mussolini is deposed
and as we get later that year, Italy formally surrenders to the allies
now with that said, Italy has surrendered but the entire country of Italy
the entire peninsula, there's still axis troops there
so the allies have to continue  to slog through 1943 and 1944
and even to 1945 to completely rid Italy of the axis powers, and especially the Germans
now Rome especially is fairly hard bombing campaigns start in Rome
in order to completely get the axis powers out of there
and that all is completely happening in 19- this is all happening in 1943
now other, other things of note
and there's many things that are happening in Europe
and once again these are just over view videos
that are happening in 1943 is American forces
early in 1943 are able to start doing bombing attacks on Germany itself
and these bombing attacks only become more and more fierce as the war progresses
another battle of note, In mid-1943 is the battle of kursk
and this is really the last offensive that the axis powers are able to mount on the Eastern Front
and they are defeated in this battle by the soviets
and then once again that allows the Soviets to start going on the offensive
so when you look at things from a European point of view
the allies are definitely, they have the bulk over the momentum now
they're now kind of putting the squeeze on the axis powers
and frankly the same thing is happening in the Pacific
especially the Americans, they are now on the offensive
they're able to get closer and closer and closer to Japan